This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the months following the invasion of Ukraine, this one piece of graffiti started popping up on walls and cities across Russia. Eight asterisks written out, all in a row. Eight asterisks instead of phrase no war. In Russian it's eight letters. Alexander Arhipova is a Russian anthropologist. She's been documenting different forms of
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在入侵乌克兰后的几个月里，俄罗斯各地的墙壁和城市里开始出现这样一件涂鸦。一连写着八个星号。用八个星号来代替“不要战争”这个词组。在俄语里它有八个字母。亚历山大·阿尔希波娃是一位俄罗斯人类学家。她一直在记录发生在俄罗斯境内的不同形式的
protest happening inside Russia. Today, Russians can face years in prison if they're caught speaking out against the war. In Russia, you cannot say war. It's forbidden. It's absolutely forbidden. And so people are using symbols like the asterisks instead. It's called language, which people are trying to hide their messages in some innocent form to pretend that they're saying some innocent things, but in reality they're not. And those innocent-looking codes are evolving fast. Take, for example, the image of a fish that started to appear across Russia. That's reporter Sophie Kodner. Back in September, a woman in Russia wrote out the Russian word for no in chalk in the
抗议活动。如今，如果俄罗斯人被抓到公开反对战争，可能会面临多年的监禁。在俄罗斯，你不能说战争。这是被禁的。绝对是被禁的。因此人们转而使用星号之类的符号。这被称为“语言”，人们试图将他们的信息隐藏在某种无辜的形式中，假装他们在说一些无辜的事情，但实际上并非如此。而且那些看起来无辜的代码正在迅速演变。比如，开始出现在俄罗斯各地的鱼的形象。那是记者索菲·科德纳。早在9月，俄罗斯的一名女子就在街道上用粉笔写下了俄语的“不”字。
street. But then, instead of writing out the Russian word for war, Boigne, she wrote just the first and last letters of the Russian word, with asterix in between. Russian authorities had caught on to the asterix thing by this point, so the woman was detained by police and tried in court. At the hearing, she told the judge that the asterix didn't represent the letters in the word war, but rather another word that spelled almost exactly the same way. She told to the judge that it means not no war, it means Niet Voble, and Voble, it's a special type of fish.
但随后，她没有写出俄语的“战争”一词（Voйна），而是只写了俄语单词的首尾字母，中间隔着星号。此时俄罗斯当局已经注意到了星号这回事，因此这名女子被警方拘留并受审。在听证会上，她告诉法官，星号并不代表“战争”一词中的字母，而是代表另一个拼写几乎完全相同的词。她告诉法官，这不代表“不要战争”，而是代表“Niet Vobla”，而Vobla（伏头鲱）是一种特殊的鱼。
The judge asked her why she wrote it. She said, I hate, I just hate fish. I can stand the smell of fish. I hate fish. The judge let her go. And because there was kind of a funny excuse, the story was picked up by the media and spread around the country. And after that, there is a lot of jokes and graffiti with a symbol of fish. And now the image of fish, the picture of fish, image of fish, the picture of fish means no war. As the restrictions on language and demonstrations in Russia have gotten more and more draconian, the dissent has gotten more and more outrageous. We are coming to the very strange paradox. The situation became much more terrible and the signs of protest became funny and funny.
法官问她为什么要这么写。她说，我讨厌，我只是讨厌鱼。我受不了鱼的味道。我讨厌鱼。法官把她放了。因为这是一个挺滑稽的借口，这个故事被媒体报道并在全国传开了。在那之后，出现了大量关于鱼的符号的笑话和涂鸦。现在，鱼的形象、鱼的图片、鱼的图像、鱼的画作就代表着“不要战争”。随着俄罗斯对语言和游示活动的限制变得越来越严苛，异见表达也变得越来越离谱。我们正迎来一个非常奇怪的悖论。局势变得越来越可怕，而抗议的标志却变得越来越滑稽。
That's why, in the very dark moments, the level of humor, political humor is going up and up. This kind of cunning protest art makes for a good story. It shows how creative and resilient people can be in the face of political repression. But it can be hard to gauge its real world impact. Painting a fish on the side of a wall probably isn't going to bring down the regime. But there is an example from Soviet history of a time when art and humor actually made a massive difference in the trajectory of a different country.
这就是为什么在极其黑暗的时刻，幽默的水平，政治幽默会不断高涨。这种狡黠的抗议艺术成就了一个好故事。它展示了人们在政治压制面前可以多么富有创造力和韧性。但很难衡量它对现实世界的影响。在墙壁上画一条鱼可能并不能推翻政权。但苏联历史上有一个例子，当时的艺术和 humor（幽默）确实对另一个国家的发展轨迹产生了巨大的影响。
Poland. In the 1980s, a Polish anti-communist group called the Orange Alternative also used a seemingly random symbol to spread its message, a mythical creature with a tiny pointed hat. And that innocent image amplified a powerful political message to the world, which ultimately contributed to the fall of the Soviet Union. Right. Mayan? Mayan? Not Joseh? The orange alternative was started by a man named Voldemort Fretrick, or Mayer, as he's
波兰。在20世纪80年代，一个名为“橙色替代运动”的波兰反共组织也使用了一个看似随机的符号来传播其信息——一个戴着尖顶小帽子的神话生物。而那个无辜的形象向世界传递了一个强有力的政治信息，最终为苏联的解体作出了贡献。对吧？玛雅？玛雅？不是约瑟夫？“橙色替代运动”是由一个名叫瓦尔德马尔·菲德里克的人发起，也就是大家所称的
called. Mayer is an artist with an eccentric reputation. I was in Europe this past summer, and so I decided to pay him a visit. This is my friend. Hello. So nice to meet you. Thank you so much for having us. Myer lives with his partner, Agni Aschka,
梅尔。梅尔是一位以古怪闻名的艺术家。我去年夏天去了欧洲，所以我决定去拜访他。这是我的朋友。你好。很高兴见到你。非常感谢你们接待我们。梅尔和他的伴侣阿格涅什卡
and their dogs, and a cabin in the Polish countryside. I'm there in August, and yellow flowers shoot up from the ground. We're close to a river, and everywhere smells damp and fresh. Meyers in his late 60s. He has long white hair that's parted on the side and sits loosely on his shoulders. He speaks slowly, even in Polish, and his canvases are all over the cabin, filled with brightly colored abstract shapes. You paint with oil? And I'll use this acrylic. Okay, I'm going to bake bread now. Agni Aschka puts a loaf of bread in the oven.
以及他们的狗住在波兰乡村的一间小屋里。我在八月份去那儿，黄色的花朵从地面破土而出。我们靠近一条河流，到处都弥漫着潮湿清新的气味。梅尔快70岁了。他留着长长的白发，中分，随意地搭在肩膀上。他说话很慢，即使说波兰语也是如此，小屋里到处都是他的画布，上面画满了色彩鲜艳的抽象形状。你用油画颜料画画吗？我也用这种丙烯颜料。好的，我现在要烤面包了。阿格涅什卡把一条面包放进烤箱里。
She's making soup for dinner, with mushroom she foraged earlier on the day. I interviewed Meyer and Agni Aschka 2, with Agni Aschka translating for Meyer as closely as possible. A w latach 80. No to ja byłem tak jak większość ludzi przeciwodnił zawolnością. So, w 1980'u, to było tak, że dużo z Polskami,
她正在做晚餐的汤，里面放了她当天早些时候采摘的蘑菇。我采访了梅尔和阿格涅什卡，阿格涅什卡尽可能准确地为梅尔翻译。在20世纪80年代。所以对我来说，就像大多数人一样，我是反对强权的。所以，在1980年，情况是这样的，很多波兰人，
i było zaśfriedem. Popierałem w sposób bezględny pokój. of the polls and he was for freedom. He was a strong supporter of peace. And I looked like a hippie. At the time Poland was one of many Eastern European countries aligned with the Communist Soviet Union, which was in the throes of an economic crisis. We were on the stress of poverty, the stress, you know, I remember very well when I was, you know, a child. I mean, I had to wait six hours to buy bread. It was not.
而且有自由。我坚决支持和平。我看起来像个嬉皮士。当时的波兰是与共产主义苏联结盟的许多东欧国家之一，正陷入经济危机之中。我们处于贫困的压力下，这种压力，你知道的，我当孩子的时候记得非常清楚。我的意思是，我不得不排队六个小时去买面包。这不是。
This was normal. In the early 1980s, Poland's government raised the price of food and other goods, but they didn't increase wages to match those price hikes. And so people couldn't afford their basic needs. It is the quintessential factor that people must remember, is that before it turned into any kind of serious movement, it was just people wanting milk. Lisa Romainenko is a Polish-American sociologist.
这是正常的。在20世纪80年代初，波兰政府提高了食品和其他商品的價格，但他们并没有提高工资来配合这些价格上涨。因此人们负担不起基本生活需求。这是人们必须记住的决定性因素，在它变成任何类型的严肃运动之前，它只是人们想要牛奶。莉萨·罗马伊连科是一位波兰裔美国社会学家。
She's written about the tactics of the orange alternative. And then of all the things the communist regime should have never done, they cut the vodka supply. And they really sent the movement in a frenzy. A labor movement took off. Under the name Solidarity. It was led by shipyard workers and it was the first independent labor union in a Soviet block country. And millions of Polish people supported it. People were having a backlash. They didn't necessarily want democracy, but they just wanted food, they wanted freedom,
她写过关于“橙色替代运动”策略的文章。然后，在共产主义政权绝不应该做的所有事情中，他们削减了伏特加的供应。他们真的让这场运动陷入了疯狂。一场劳工运动腾空出世。以“团结工会”为名。它由造船厂工人领导，是苏联集团国家中第一个独立的工会。数百万波兰人支持它。人们正在产生强烈反弹。他们不一定想要民主，但他们只是想要食物，想要自由，
they wanted to be able to dress, they wanted expression of the arts. And you know, once you take away vodka and children's food there was nothing to live for so people became very very powerful very courageous on and always on the streets But the communist regime responded swiftly placing the whole country under martial law in But the Communist regime responded swiftly, placing the whole country under martial law in 1981. The armed forces now rule in Poland, with martial law and the threat of execution for those who break it. At home, the media became heavily censored.
他们想要能够穿衣打扮，他们想要艺术的表达。你知道的，一旦你拿走了伏特加和孩子们的食物，就没什么好留恋的了，所以人们变得非常非常强大，非常勇敢，而且总是在街头上。但共产主义政权迅速作出反应，在1981年宣布全国进入戒严令。但共产主义政权迅速作出反应，在1981年宣布全国进入戒严令。武装部队现在统治着波兰，实行戒严令，并对违反者处以死刑的威胁。在国内，媒体受到严厉审查。
Curfews were put into place, and everyday movement was restricted. And during this time, under martial law, people would leave graffiti with messages supporting solidarity on walls around Poland, including in the city of Rotswaff, where Meyer lived. In most of the graffiti in Poland at the time it was written, it was just written slogans. But there were different graffiti preachers with communism. So for example, away with the communism, we attack solidarnovalds,
宵禁开始实施，日常出行受到限制。在这期间，在戒严令下，人们在波兰各地的墙上留下支持团结工会信息的涂鸦，包括梅尔居住的弗罗茨瓦夫市。当时波兰的大多数涂鸦都是写出来的，只是一些写下来的口号。但也有不同的涂鸦批评共产主义。例如，打倒共产主义，我们攻击团结工会，
or solidarity in struggle, we'll win. But these slogans wouldn't last very long. And then as soon as they were written, the authorities would come with a fresh bucket of paint and just cover them up, so you would have all these paint spots on lower. Myer grew fascinated with these paint spots. He was an undergraduate art history student at the time, and he was really into surrealism,
或者团结奋斗，我们必胜。但这些口号不会持续太久。而且一旦它们被写出来，当局就会带着一桶新鲜油漆赶到，把它们盖住，所以在楼上你就会看到所有这些油漆斑点。梅尔对这些油漆斑点着迷了。他当时是一名本科艺术史学生，他非常迷恋超现实主义，
which is all about using your irrational, unconscious mind, liberating yourself from the boundaries of reality. And some of those spots were very interesting from the artistic point of view. i zamiast w zamiastu. I zamiastu, które są bardzo wciąż w tym artystycznym pointe. I to, że się zastanawiam, że trzeba zrobić zrozumień z mięsztą. I to, że oni się znam i nie wiem, co się może zrobić z nich artystycznym. Więc to, że oni się znam, co się znam, co się znam. Więc to, że oni się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co się znam, co sięwyczaj, i z powrotem w publicznym. Wspóźnie, że to był wysok, i po prostu pójdę na wiołkę z górą w górę. Wspóźnie, zbyt na szkodzie, zainteresowali na szkodzie.
这完全关乎利用你非理性的、无意识的思维，把自己从现实的界限中解放出来。其中一些斑点从艺术的角度来看非常有趣。以及……还有……从艺术的角度来看非常有趣。我想知道如何理解这种混合。我想知道人们可以用它们来做什么艺术。所以……（波兰语背景音）……在公共场所。后来，这很高，我只是去兜风……（波兰语背景音）……
Wspóźnie, że po prostu pójdę na wiołkę w górę w kastium. Mamy zainteresowali na wiołkę w kastium. I chyba w ręku miał ojre, że przypominam butelkę piwa. I wciąż stąd był wśródiosenie biednie w biecie. I wtedy powstało miło, że trzeba kraszolutki malować na tych plama. I nie miał to w porządku, że to jest właśnie, co to będzie to zgrzymać na tych zgrzymi.
（波兰语背景音）……然后诞生了，需要把这些斑点画得可爱一点。这并没有什么不对，因为这正是将要发生的事情……
Somier zaczęli odpłynąć z dźwięk z południcą z południcą z południcą. Znaczył w biecie, że piosenie z południcą z południcą. decided to paint a stick figure dwarf with a little pointed hat. Instead of the beer, he put a flower in its hand. Tell me more about why a dwarf. I think that's why you saw me in front of my head. I'm the picture of what he told you because he was high, because he woke up, because he saw this real image of this dwarf with the, and to all of you know, with the bottle in his hand, that's a feeling he had.
索米尔开始……（波兰语背景音）……决定画一个拿着花的火柴人侏儒。他没有拿啤酒，而是在手里放了一朵花。跟我多讲讲为什么是侏儒。我想这就是为什么你在我脑海前看到我。我是他告诉你事情的写照，因为他喝高了，因为他醒来时，因为他看到了这个侏儒的真实形象，手里拿着瓶子，那是他当时的感受。
It was a feeling. It's not making an conscious effort to make it a certain way. It's just following your gods. In Polish, the word for this dwarf elf, known like mythical creature, is crasnellutic, and they are a big part of Polish folklore, especially children's tales. They're less like the dwarves from the Lord of the Rings, and more like the barwars, like little spirits who live in your house and cause mischief. So for example, we have sayings, the ruby with a crossnalutki, you know,
这是一种感觉。这不是刻意要把它做成某种特定样子的努力。这只是跟随你的内心。在波兰语中，这种小精灵、被称为神话生物的侏儒的词是“crasnolidki”，它们是波兰民间传说尤其是童话故事的重要组成部分。它们不太像《指环王》里的矮人，而更像是家精，就像住在你家里并恶作剧的小精灵。所以例如，我们有这样的说法，是小侏儒干的，你知道的，
little dwarves did it. For example, somebody, you know, did something wrong and he says, it's not me. Oh no, it's a little dwarves did it, you know. And then we have this, so may a stationary cross-nolute, we are the dwarves. Can you sing it? You don't want me to. Okay, I'll sing for you just the first line. May a stationary cross-nolute key, hapsa-sa, hapsa-sa, Okay, that's an additional instrumental. So Mayeron, some of his artist friends friends started painting dwarves on walls all around
小侏儒干的。例如，某人做错了什么，然后他说，不是我。哦不，是小侏儒干的，你知道的。然后我们有这个，所以梅尔在画小侏儒，我们是侏儒。你能唱一下吗？你不会想听的。好吧，我只为你唱第一行。梅尔的小侏儒，hapsa-sa，hapsa-sa，好吧，那是一个额外的乐器演奏。所以梅尔和一些艺术家朋友开始在四周的墙上画侏儒
Vrotzwaff. They had to be careful because the city was still under martial law, so they would do it secretly at night. And the result was a surreal stack of images painted over each other. First you had the original solidarity slogan, then a layer of paint that the authorities had used to cover up that message. And then those blockages of fresh paint became the perfect canvas for Meyer and his friends to paint a jolly little dwarf. The orange alternative painted hundreds of these dwarves in cities across Poland and the
弗罗茨瓦夫。他们必须小心翼翼，因为这座城市仍然处于戒严状态，所以他们会在夜间秘密进行。结果是重叠画着的超现实的图像堆栈。首先你有最初的团结工会口号，然后是当局用来掩盖该信息的油漆层。然后，那些新鲜油漆的色块成了梅尔和他的朋友们画一个快乐小侏儒的完美画布。“橙色替代运动”在波兰各地的城市里画了数百个这样的侏儒，
silly images resonated with Polish people in part because they broke through the monotony of martial law. Because nothing was appearing during the martial law and there was sudden something would appear that is new that was already a great idea by itself. After about a year and a half of martial law, the Polish government had regained some control over the country. Thousands of solidarity activists had been arrested and many remained in jail. Meanwhile outside of Poland, international pressure was mounting. Sanctions put in place by the United States were hurting the Polish economy.
这些滑稽的图像在波兰人中引起了共鸣，部分原因是它们打破了戒严令的单调。因为在戒严期间没有任何东西出现，突然间有什么新的东西出现了，这本身就已经是一个伟大的创意了。在大约一年半的戒严之后，波兰政府重新获得了对该国的一些控制权。数千名团结工会积极分子被捕，许多人仍在狱中。与此同时，在波兰境外，国际压力正在加剧。美国实施的制裁正在损害波兰经济。
And in July of 1983, martial law was officially lifted. I actually got on a plane with my father. Two days after martial law was lifted and experienced Poland as close to having lived through the hell as any, you know, future scholar could have been. Lisa Romainant go again.
1983年7月，戒严令正式解除。我实际上在戒严令解除两天后和我父亲一起搭飞机，体验了波兰作为任何未来学者所能经历的宛如人间地狱的生活。莉萨·罗马伊连科再次说道。
I had my own personal soldier with a gun pointed at me and following me the day I arrived in Warsaw, so although I was a teenager, you know, just to be able to see what the aftermath of what the worst of the times the people were living under. Even though martial law had been lifted, political repression went on. And so anti-communist groups continued to organize underground. The Solidarity Labor Movement was allied closely with the Catholic Church and had the support of the Pope. Which was a problem for myer and his artist friends. They supported Solidarity, but they also wanted to distance themselves from the Catholic Church.
我到达华沙的那天，有我自己的专属士兵用枪指着我并跟踪我，所以尽管我当时是个青少年，你知道的，仅仅能够看到人们生活在最糟糕时代之后的余波。尽管戒严令已经解除，政治镇压仍在继续。因此反共组织继续在地下组织起来。“团结工会”劳工运动与天主教会紧密结盟，并得到了教皇的支持。这给梅尔和他的艺术家朋友们带来了麻烦。他们支持团结工会，但他们也想与天主教会保持距离。
Being artists, they said, well, we have to be in between Vatican Yellow and Communist Red, and the color we must focus on is the blend of the Yellow and the Red, which is orange. And so, the orange alternative was born. And so, the orange alternative was born. The artists and the orange alternative were anti-thoreterian and advocates for free expression. They published a satirical, political magazine and began staging ridiculous demonstrations that they called happenings. They took the dwarf graffiti, which by then had popped up all over Poland, and brought it to life in the real world. Everybody put on an orange, an orange elf hat, and an orange scarf, and pranced and danced through the streets like there was no tomorrow. Since they couldn't advocate for their own rights, they would stage skits and
作为艺术家，他们说，好吧，我们必须介于梵蒂冈黄和共产主义红之间，而我们必须关注的颜色是黄色和红色的混合，也就是橙色。于是，“橙色替代运动”诞生了。于是，“橙色替代运动”诞生了。“橙色替代运动”的艺术家们是反威权主义者，也是言论自由的倡导者。他们出版了一本讽刺性的政治杂志，并开始上演他们称之为“偶发艺术”（happenings）的荒谬示威活动。他们将当时已经遍布波兰各地的侏儒涂鸦带到了现实世界中。每个人都戴上橙色的橙色精灵帽和橙色围巾，像没有明天一样在街上欢蹦乱跳。既然他们不能为自己的权利发声，他们就会上演滑稽短剧并
sing songs that advocated for the rights of the cross-noludic. I mean, when you looked at the videos and the footage from back in those days, and you see, you know, tanks rolling through the streets like you saw in Tiananmen Square and rather than a guy holding his like, you know, supermarket bags, you see people donning orange caps and orange capes, large, large groups of orange elves. So wherever those tanks were going, they had to keep stopping because these elves were just dancing. And it just cracked people up at a time when they really needed it.
唱着为小侏儒权利发声的歌曲。我的意思是，当你看到当年那些视频和素材时，你看到坦克像你在天安门广场看到的那样在街上滚滚向前，而人们手里拿的不是超市购物袋，而是看到人们戴着橙色的帽子和橙色的斗篷，大群大群的橙色精灵。所以无论那些坦克开到哪里，它们都不得不停下来，因为这些精灵一直在跳舞。这在人们最需要的时候让他们捧腹大笑。
Spontaneous laughter was so hard to come by, and that these artists and performers were trying so hard to get people to laugh. But the Orange Alternative provided more than just comic relief. They also started handing out basic goods that were in short supply and Poland. At their happenings, they would give out things like toilet paper and tampons. They had boxes and boxes of sanitary protection. They really had their finger on the poles of what the people really wanted. So if you showed up at a happening, you were going to walk away with something that was really crucial for your family's safety. And they were brilliant in that way.
自发的笑声是如此难得，而这些艺术家和表演者却在竭尽全力让人们笑出来。但“橙色替代运动”提供的不仅仅是喜剧效果。他们还开始分发波兰短缺的基本生活物资。在他们的“偶发艺术”活动中，他们会分发诸如卫生纸和卫生棉条之类的东西。他们有成箱成箱的卫生防护用品。他们真正摸清了人们真正想要什么脉搏。所以如果你出现在一场活动中，你就会带走一些对你家庭安全至关重要东西离开。他们在这一点上非常聪明。
The police didn't treat the orange alternative lightly. There were many arrests. But the cops also didn't really know what to make of these artists and costumes, handing out tampons. Once after Maya was arrested, he was sitting in the back of a police car. And you heard the officer up front call for backup. Like, hey, there are a bunch of dwarfs running around down here. So the other guy responded, are you drunk? What dwarfs?
警方并没有轻易对待“橙色替代运动”。有许多人被捕。但警察也不知道该如何处理这些穿着奇装异服、分发卫生棉条的艺术家。有一次，梅尔被捕后，坐在警车后座上。你听到前面的警察呼叫支援。就像，嘿，这里有一群侏儒到处乱跑。于是另一个人回答说，你喝醉了吗？什么侏儒？
Basically, the police also started talking about them as of dwarfs, you know, not men dressed as dwarfs, but as dwarfs. And that's what made it really, you know, even more interesting. It made a joke of the police and showed everyone just how absurd the situation they were living in had become. In the realistic situations, you know, people running around after dwarfs, you know, and I mean, come on. That's just so surrealistic. People even policemen, they understand they participate in something completely goofy.
基本上，警察也开始把他们当作侏儒来谈论，你知道的，不是打扮成侏儒的人，而是作为侏儒。这才是真正让它变得，你知道的，更加有趣的地方。它把警察变成了一个笑话，并向所有人展示了他们生活的环境变得多么荒谬。在现实的情况下，你知道的，人们在侏儒后面跑来跑去，你知道的，我的天哪。这简直太超现实了。人们甚至警察，他们明白他们参与了一些完全滑稽的事情。
And it was even absurd to your typical communist. So the soldiers were laughing, the tank drivers were laughing, and even Moscow had to be like chocolate. And what I like about the Oriental alternative is that it's very peaceful because the force meets vacuum. If you're the force meets another force, you have a conflict. But if the force meets vacuum, the force dissipates. And that's what Orange Alternative is for me.
而且对你典型的共产主义者来说这也太荒谬了。所以士兵们在笑，坦克驾驶员在笑，甚至莫斯科也一定觉得不可思议。而我喜欢“橙色替代运动”的地方在于它是非常和平的，因为武力遇到了真空。如果你是一股武力遇到了另一股武力，你就会有冲突。但如果武力遇到了真空，武力就会消散。这就是“橙色替代运动”对我的意义。
By 1988, Poland was alive with revolution. The Solidarity Labor Movement was holding mass demonstrations, and the Orange Alternatives happening grew huge. They spread the cities across Poland, including Warsaw and Lotes. Thousands of people would gather to chant dwarves, dwarves, dwarves. The war of the people, the war of the people, the war of the people.
到1988年，波兰到处都充满了革命的生机。“团结工会”劳工运动正在举行大规模示威，“橙色替代运动”的活动规模变得非常庞大。它们蔓延到波兰各地的城市，包括华沙和罗兹。成千上万的人聚集在一起高呼：侏儒，侏儒，侏儒。人民的战争，人民的战争，人民的战争。
By bringing the militia to the point of ridicule, basically people started losing fear of militia. And that allowed the people to free them to do things in the streets that they wanted to do and to, for example, come to happenings with their own ideas, you know, they stopped being afraid. So it broke the fear. You cannot be afraid of things that are ridiculous and funny
通过将民兵逼到荒谬的地步，基本上人们开始失去对民兵的恐惧。这让人们解放了自己，去做他们想在街上做的事，例如，带着他们自己的想法来到“偶发艺术”活动中，你知道的，他们不再害怕了。所以它打破了恐惧。你不可能对荒谬可笑的事情感到害怕
unless you're a politician. No, you're very afraid. Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, and was percolating in Poland, a sense that Polish people had their own identity separate from the Soviet Union, and the cross-nalytic played a role. They were these distinctly Polish characters from Polish fairy tales. And an orange alternative understood that it was between Polish people in the military, Polish leaders of the communist government, Polish artists, Polish steel workers. This was a conversation between us that we had to have. And as that Polish identity was growing stronger, the end of communism was getting closer and
除非你是个政客。不，你非常害怕。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，在波兰酝酿着一种感觉，即波兰人拥有区别于苏联的自身身份，而小侏儒发挥了作用。它们是波兰童话故事中鲜明的波兰角色。“橙色替代运动”明白，这是波兰人民与军队、共产主义政府的波兰领导人、波兰艺术家、波兰钢铁工人之间的事。这是我们必须进行的对话。随着波兰人身份认同的日益增强，共产主义的终结也越来越
closer. But the late 1980s, people all over central and Eastern Europe were taking to the streets and demanding freedom and democratic reforms. The Soviet Union was losing its grip on the people. Poland today came one step closer to becoming the first East-Block country not led by communists in more than 40 years. President Yerazelski, for me... In 1989 facing pressure from the public, Poland's government agreed to hold parliamentary
近。但到了20世纪80年代末，中东欧各地的人们走上街头，要求自由和民主改革。苏联对人民的控制正在减弱。今天的波兰向成为40多年来第一个不由共产主义者领导的东欧国家又迈进了一步。雅鲁泽尔斯基总统，对我来说……1989年，面对公众的压力，波兰政府同意举行议会
elections. When the votes were counted, leaders of the Solidarity Labor Movement won out over the communists. Communism fell in Poland, and it led to a domino effect that ended up taking down the entire Soviet Union. It's hard to say exactly how important the artists of the Orangeal Turned of War to Poland peacefully winning its independence. But Lisa gives them a lot of credit. I would attribute the successes of the entire revolution and the entire lack of bloodshed, which could have been much worse than it was, to the amazing brilliance of Mayer and the Arngel alternative. With any type of resistance or non-conformity, it's easy to dismiss it as silly and trivial.
选举。当选票被统计出来时，“团结工会”劳工运动的领导人击败了共产主义者。波兰的共产主义垮台了，并引发了多米诺骨牌效应，最终摧毁了整个苏联。很难说“橙色替代运动”的艺术家们对波兰和平赢得独立有多大重要性。但莉萨给了他们很高的赞誉。我将整场革命的成功以及完全没有流血——本可能比实际情况糟糕得多——归功于梅尔和“橙色替代运动”的惊人才华。对于任何形式的抵抗或不妥协，人们很容易将其贬低为愚蠢和琐碎。
Joy Numeira is a historian who studies Russia in Eastern Europe. Or, on the other hand, it's easy to lionize it as bold, as consequential, as bringing down the regime one little figure at a time. And I think the truth is very much somewhere in between. Joy recently wrote about a protest movement happening in Russia now, which some people have compared to the orange alternative. It's called the Little Picketers. The first time I came across the Little Picketers was actually in a photo in a Polish newspaper, and the author of that article made the comparison to orange alternative.
乔·努梅拉是一位研究俄罗斯和东欧的历史学家。或者，另一方面，人们也很容易将其浪漫化，认为它是勇敢的、有重大影响的、一次一个小小形象地推翻政权。而我认为真相在很大程度上介于两者之间。乔最近写了一篇关于目前在俄罗斯发生的抗议运动的文章，有些人将其与“橙色替代运动”进行比较。它被称为“小纠察队”。我第一次遇到“小纠察队”其实是在波兰报纸的一张照片中，那篇文章的作者将其与“橙色替代运动”进行了比较。
Oh, like this looks a little bit like those dwarfs from Frotswap in the 80s. The little picketers are small clay figurines about the size of the palm of your hand that are placed throughout Russian cities. They're cute and silly and colorful. In Russian it's called modinky piquet, which means little protest. So yeah, they are miniature protesters. Some of them hold peace signs or Ukrainian flags or anti-war messages.
哦，这看起来有点像80年代弗罗茨瓦夫的那些侏儒。“小纠察队”是只有手掌大小的小型粘土雕像，被放置在俄罗斯城市的各处。它们可爱、滑稽且色彩缤纷。在俄语中它被称为“malen'kiye pikety”，意思是小型抗议。所以是的，它们是微型抗议者。其中一些人举着和平标志、乌克兰国旗或反战标语。
One of them is pictured holding a fish. It's easy for anyone to get some clay and make a little picketter and then discreetly drop it off in a public space without anyone else noticing. They usually get thrown away pretty quickly by Russian authorities, but before that happens, a photo is taken and submitted to an Instagram account. Joy likes the little picketers in part because of how different they look from the imagery coming out of the regime.
其中一个被拍摄到手里拿着一条鱼。任何人都可以很容易地弄到一些粘土，做一个小纠察队员，然后悄悄地把它放在公共场所，而不会引起别人的注意。它们通常很快就会被俄罗斯当局扔掉，但在那之前，会拍下照片并提交到一个Instagram账号。乔喜欢“小纠察队”，部分原因在于它们看起来与该政权散发的形象截然不同。
The most prominent pro-war symbol in Russia right now is the Z. You'll see these big aggressive Z's break-painted on tanks and cars. They look intimidating and warlike. And the little picketers just feel like the opposite, which is in itself subversive. This idea of trying to create something in contrast to the dominant reality around you,
目前俄罗斯最突出的亲战标志是“Z”。你会看到这些巨大的、具有攻击性的“Z”字被喷涂在坦克和汽车上。它们看起来令人生畏且充满好战色彩。而“小纠察队”给人的感觉恰恰相反，这本身就是颠覆性的。这种试图创造出与你周围占主导地位的现实形成对比的事物的想法，
which can seem hegemonic and overwhelming, trying to create little strange things that are at odds with that dominant reality and that point to some kind of other possibilities or other ideas or other ways of acting or being in the world other than what the state wants you to do and think. I spoke to the creator of the little picketers who will keep anonymous for safety reasons. He said he sometimes hears criticism that Russians aren't doing enough to protest the war. And that's a position of a critic Russian people. You're just viewers. You didn't do anything.
这种现实可能显得具有霸权色彩和压倒一切，试图创造出一些与这种占主导地位的现实不一致的奇怪小东西，它们指向除国家要求你做和想的事情之外的其他可能性、其他想法或在世界上行动或生存的其他方式。我采访了“小纠察队”的创造者，出于安全原因，他将保持匿名。他说他有时听到批评，认为俄罗斯人没有做足够的事情来抗议战争。这也是批评俄罗斯人民的立场。你们只是旁观者。你们什么也没做。
Why don't you go out on the streets and demonstrate, of course, yeah, a great idea. He worries that even talking about the war inside his own home could get him arrested and thrown in jail. I feel very paranoid and started to hearing voices behind the walls of my neighbors. And that was the paranoid which I shared with very, very huge amount of different, of all Russians, I think. You know that your neighbors can call to police anytime. It's very, very scary thing. But despite this constant fear and anxiety, he still feels compelled to do something.
为什么你们不走上街头去游行，当然，是的，好主意。他担心，甚至在自己家里谈论战争也可能导致他被捕并锒铛入狱。我感到非常偏执，开始听到邻居墙后传来的声音。这是我和绝大多数甚至所有俄罗斯人共同拥有的偏执，我想。你知道你的邻居随时可以报警。这是一件非常非常可怕的事情。但尽管有这种持续的恐惧和焦虑，他仍然觉得自己必须做点什么。
He thinks a lot of Russians do, which is why he created the little picketers. For Russian people, I think it's a training machine mostly. The feel yourself, feel your muscle of protest. To therapy yourself, yeah, I did it, it's not important, but it's important. It's important because it's not so important. It's daily routine. In another way protest is to feel who are you? Can you do this? It's fun and that's funny because again, I do this small thing. Of course I can The little picketers are one of a number of ways that some people inside Russia are using
他认为很多俄罗斯人也是这么想的，这就是他创作“小纠察队”的原因。对俄罗斯人来说，我认为这主要是一个训练机器。感受你自己，感受你的抗议肌肉。自我治疗，是的，我做了，这不重要，但这很重要。它之所以重要是因为它没那么重要。这是日常生活。以另一种方式抗议是为了感受你是谁？你能做到这一点吗？这很有趣，而且很滑稽，因为再次强调，我做了这件小事。当然我可以。“小纠察队”是俄罗斯境内一些人用来表达对一场非常严肃、残酷的战争——一场已经夺去数万人生灵的战争——的异见和不满的多种方式之一。
play and humor to express their dissent against a very serious brutal war, a war that's already killed tens of thousands. If nothing else, these small actions offer self-preservation, like a way to save your own soul. And you never know, sometimes a silly little symbol catches on. Sovicotner goes hunting for dwarfs after this. So we are back with reporter Soficodner. Thank you for bringing in that story, Sofic. I really loved it.
如果说别的没有了，这些微小的行动至少提供了自我保护，就像一种拯救自己灵魂的方式。你永远不会知道，有时一个愚蠢的小标志就会流行起来。索菲·科德纳接下来要去寻找侏儒。所以我们回到了记者索菲·科德纳身边。谢谢你带来那个故事，索菲。我真的很喜欢。
Thanks for signing off on my trip to Poland. Anytime. I mean, it sounded delightful. How did you enjoy it? Poland was super interesting. As you know, I went to the Polish countryside and interviewed Meyer at his cabin, which was really beautiful and peaceful. But I also went to the city of Rotswaff, that's where Meyer lived and where the orange alternative came to be.
谢谢你批准我去波兰的行程。随时都可以。我的听起来很愉快。你玩得开心吗？波兰超级有趣。如你所知，我去了波兰乡村，在梅尔的小屋里采访了他，那里真的非常美丽和宁静。但我还去了弗罗茨瓦夫市，那是梅尔居住过的地方，“橙色替代运动”也是在那里诞生的。
And I was really excited to find that a big thing tourists do there is go hunting for cross Noludik. So what does hunting for cross Noludic mean? Like what it would is door hunting in tail. So let me set the scene. Wordswaff has this big medieval market square in the middle of its old town. It's surrounded by these tall sort of pastel colored buildings that have amazingly detailed moldings. There's actually a spiral motif, like a swirl on a lot of the buildings that I'm obsessed with. It sounds beautiful, really charming. Yes, it was very, very charming. But anyway, Vrotsov also has these little bronze statues all over town.
我非常兴奋地发现，游客在那里的一大乐事就是去寻找小侏儒。那么寻找小侏儒意味着什么？就像捉迷藏里的寻矮人一样。让我来搭建一下场景。弗罗茨瓦夫老城区中心有一个巨大的中世纪集市广场。它四周环绕着高大的、某种程度上是粉蜡色调的建筑，有着令人惊叹的精致模具。事实上，许多建筑上都有一个螺旋图案，就像一个漩涡，让我着迷。听起来很美，真的很迷人。是的，非常非常迷人。不过无论如何，弗罗茨瓦夫全城也有很多这样的小青铜雕像。
They're the statues of Crasneludic dwarves with tiny pointed shoes, pointed hats. They sort of look like garden gnomes, but all bronze. And there are hundreds of them, something like 450 of them. Oh, wow. Yeah, they basically have their own world within Frotswaff. And Taurus run around, try to spot them all. I actually hopped on a free dwarf tour while I was there with a local guide.
它们是“crasnoludki”侏儒的雕像，穿着尖尖的鞋子，戴着尖尖的帽子。它们看起来有点像花园里的地精，但全都是青铜的。有成百上千个，大概有450个左右。哦，哇。是的，它们基本上在弗罗茨瓦夫内部拥有自己的世界。游客们四处奔跑，试图把它们全部找出来。我在那里时，实际上和一个当地导游一起参加了一个免费的寻侏儒之旅。
So, welcome to Frotswaff, everybody. And as I have said, first of all, we'll take a little walk around this square to see some of those statues that will be like the first part of the tour and as you can see we saw tons of dwarves on the store they're all posed in different ways like there's one smiling and holding a sunflower I personally love this one sleeping next to a little bronze seller door this is usually referred to as the entrance to the dwarf underworld because you can see like the entrance going down.
欢迎大家来到弗罗茨瓦夫。正如我所说，首先，我们将在这个广场周围散步，看看其中一些雕像，这将是旅游的第一部分，正如你所见，我们在这次旅行中看到了大量的侏儒，它们的姿势各不相同，比如有一个在微笑并拿着向日葵。我个人特别喜欢这个，它正睡在一个小青铜地窖门旁边，这通常被称为通往侏儒地下世界的入口，因为你可以看到类似于向下的入口。
And some of them are harder to find than others. Some of them are like moving. There are for example dwarves in lots of trams, in lots of boats, in public transport. Many of them are indoors. For example, in a moment we are going to pass post office. There is a dwarf in the post office. Little further there is KF2 restaurant. Inside of the restaurant there is a dwarf eating hot wings, for example, right? That one's sitting on a little bronze KFC bucket. And a lot of the crafts and analytics are advertisements like that. They advertise for local businesses.
有些比其他的更难找到。其中一些是会动的。例如，在许多电车里、许多船只里、公共交通工具里都有侏儒。它们很多都在室内。例如，等一下我们要经过邮局。邮局里就有一个侏儒。再往前一点是肯德基餐厅。餐厅里面有一个正在吃辣翅的侏儒，比如这样，对吧？那个正坐在一个青铜的肯德基全家桶上。许多小侏儒都是这样的广告。它们为当地企业做广告。
Like there's one outside of bank that's using a little bronze ATM. There's one eating ice cream, outside an ice cream shop. Another one is drinking vodka, outside a bar. Those businesses, they actually pay a lot of money to have those doors, because this is like their advertisement. So, if you'd like to have such a door, for example, like your podcast, to open an office in Vrottov, you'd like to have a door at your door. Yeah?
比如银行外面有一个正在使用小型青铜自动提款机的侏儒。冰淇淋店外面有一个在吃冰淇淋。另一个在酒吧外面喝伏特加。这些企业实际上花了很多钱来拥有这些侏儒，因为这就像是他们的广告。所以，如果你想拥有这样一个侏儒，例如像你的播客一样，在弗罗茨瓦夫开设一个办公室，你希望在你的门口有一个侏儒。对吧？
99 PI, cross the literally. I'm all for it. It would be a reason enough to open up an office in Poland. That would be amazing. Some a little Polish studio. Oh, I love it. Yeah. So for the most part, everyone I met in Vroza was a huge fan of the dwarf statues.
99 PI，字面意义上的跨界。我完全赞成。这将是去波兰开设办公室的足够理由。那太棒了。某个小型波兰工作室。哦，我太喜欢了。是的，总的来说，我在弗罗茨瓦夫遇到的每个人都是侏儒雕像的超级粉丝。
People love them except Meyer. Meyer hates them. I think I can guess why, but tell me, what is he hate the cross-niluvic around the town? So the first cross-niluvic statue was put up in 2001, and that one was explicitly in homage to the orange alternative. It's on a pedestal in the middle of a street where a lot of the orange alternative happenings went down, but since then, as more and more dwarf statues have gone up, they've basically become a marketing play for the town at large. And the history is kind of backseat.
人们都很喜欢它们，除了梅尔。梅尔讨厌它们。我想我能猜到原因，但告诉我，他为什么讨厌镇上的“crasnoludki”？所以第一个“crasnoludki”雕像是在2001年竖立的，那个雕像明确是为了向“橙色替代运动”致敬。它位于一条街道中间的底座上，许多“橙色替代运动”的活动正是在那里进行的，但从那以后，随着越来越多的侏儒雕像拔地而起，它们基本上成了整个城镇的营销噱头。而历史则退居其次了。
Do the dwarves around town, do they work to reinforce this revolutionary history, or is it really just marketing at this point, is it all been obscured by other uses of the dwarf? Yeah, I would not say that they reinforce the history in any way. Okay. I think the people who lived through the Revolution in Poland remember the orange alternative for the most part, but other than that, it's not really common knowledge anymore. It's not like something that's being taught in schools in Poland. I mean, it's not super surprising, because like 60s revolutionary stuff in this country
镇上的侏儒，它们是否起到了强化这种革命历史的作用，还是说此时此刻它真的只是营销，一切都被侏儒的其他用途所掩盖了？是的，我不会说它们以任何方式强化了历史。好吧。我认为在波兰经历过革命的人们大体上还记得“橙色替代运动”，但除此之外，它已经不再是常识了。它不再像是波兰学校里教授的东西。我的意思是，这并不是超级令人惊讶，因为这个国家的60年代革命事迹
isn't really taught in schools that much, but it is kind of disappointing, especially since those symbols are everywhere. Right. And what really bothers Meyer about it is that the city of Rotswap itself started using a cross-noludic drawing in their marketing materials, like as a logo. And it looked a lot like Meyer's original cross-noludic graffiti. So to him, it was a copyright issue, a plagiarism issue. He actually sued the city a few years back, anyone. So they don't use that cross-niludic logo anymore. Wow. OK, so he has a personal stake in this and then overusing or misappropriating that logo,
在学校里并没有被教导太多，但确实有点令人失望，特别是考虑到这些符号到处都是。对吧。真正让梅尔烦恼的是，弗罗茨瓦夫市本身开始在他们的营销材料中使用“crasnoludki”的画作，比如作为一个标志。而且它看起来非常像梅尔最初的“crasnoludki”涂鸦。所以对她来说，这是一个版权问题、抄袭问题。几年前他 실제로 起诉了这座城市，并且赢了。所以他们不再使用那个“crasnoludki”标志了。哇。好吧，所以他对此有切身利益，然后是过度使用或盗用该标志，
like even to the point of plagiarism. That's interesting. Yeah, and I really liked my tour guides take on the whole thing. Let's say that this, you know, the legal suit, the lawsuit he filed. This is one more happening on his behalf, right? Because he was creating funny, happening sexual life. And this is also maybe like the last time he was trying to kind of, you know, make people question this whole story, whether it's like, okay,
甚至到了抄袭的地步。这很有趣。是的，我真的很喜欢我的导游对整件事的看法。可以说，这个，你知道的，他提起的诉讼。这是他代表自己进行的又一次“偶发艺术”活动，对吧？因为他过去常常在现实生活中创造有趣的活动。这也是他可能最后一次试图让人们对整个故事产生质疑，无论是像，好吧，
to use a symbol of anti-communist era for marketing, right? So this is just another big happening, a big metacommentary by the Orange alternative. I like that interpretation, that's pretty fun. Exactly. Well, thank you, Sophie. This is so much fun. I just enjoyed the story, and it was like, Thanks, Roman.
用反共时代的标志来做营销，对吧？所以这只是另一件大事，“橙色替代”运动的一个重大元评论。我喜欢这种解读，非常有趣。完全正确。好的，谢谢你，索菲。这太有趣了。我只是很享受这个故事，就像是，谢谢，罗曼。
99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Sophie Cotner, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, original music director, sound Swan Rihau, with additional music by Jenny Conley Driesos, John Newfeld, and Nate Query. Sound mix by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Delaney Hall is their senior editor, Kurt Colstead is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barupé, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Jason Dillion, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Harry Tarpe, Martha Golonka, Agneska Griez, Megan Zirez, Carly Olson,
本周的《99%无形》由索菲·科特纳制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，原创音乐总监兼声音设计为斯旺·里豪，珍妮·康利·德里索斯、约翰·纽费尔德和内特·奎里提供额外音乐。马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音，格雷厄姆·海沙负责事实核查。德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、维维安·莱、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、杰森·迪利昂、拉谢马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本周要特别感谢哈里·塔尔佩、玛莎·戈隆卡、阿涅斯卡·格里兹、梅根·齐雷兹、卡莉·奥尔森，
and the Orange Alternative Foundation. 99% invisible is part of the Stitcher and Serious Exam podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or on Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to other
以及“橙色替代”基金会。《99%无形》是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的上城区潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上向我@Roman Mars以及向节目@99PI发送推文，也可以在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上找到我们。你可以找到指向其他
stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. And so people are using symbols like the asterisks, the asterisks instead. And so people are using symbols like the asterisks, like the asterisks, like the asterisks, like the asterisks, like the asterisks, like the asterisks, you're gonna have to come back, I can't read those ends, I'm gonna write. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我喜欢的Stitcher节目以及99PI过去所有节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。所以人们现在用星号之类的符号来代替。所以人们用星号之类的符号，像星号，像星号，像星号，像星号，像星号，像星号，你得回来了，我看不清那些结尾，我要写。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。